[Music]
trans athletes now compete in so many
sports sprint cyclist rachel mckinnon
set a world record for her age two years
ago
this year laurel hubbard grabbed the
headlines at the olympics but it was
quinn a canadian footballer who became
the first trans and non-binary olympic
champion in women's football
this month in mixed martial arts alana
mclaughlin became the second trans
competitor to fight in the women's
competition
for the past 18 months the sports
councils in the uk have been grappling
with how grassroots mass participation
sports can create a level playing field
their conclusion is that you can't have
it all the women's sports can't be
completely inclusive while also being
fully fair to everyone taking part
it means sports should consider if they
need an extra category of competition
sports can't continue under the illusion
that you can balance inclusion safety
and fairness all in one offering they're
going to have to make a choice they have
to prioritize now either trans inclusion
as their priority in which case they
have to acknowledge that that will be
unsafe and unfair for women
or they prioritize the integrity of
women's sport and find alternatives for
trans inclusion
but the consequences for a trans
footballer like natalie who plays in
hampshire are far-reaching
i think it's created a
culture of
um
being worried about whether we should be
including trans people and i think
that's a real shame because i've got a
lot a lot out being involved in sport
and i know that there are so many trans
people out there that would love to get
that same um joy out of being involved
in sport and i worry that today we've
pushed them away the british triathlon
they believe nothing should deter people
from having a go and are weighing up
whether extra categories of competition
are right for their sport we have
categories for disability but we also
have many many categories in triathlon
for age as well so it's something that
we're quite well used to and i think it
could give us an advantage when we are
considering how to build on this
guidance and form our own policies in
triathlon
there is no perfect solution but uk
sports are now tackling this and trying
to get it right for everyone
tom parmenter sky news love bro